y su familia hacen parte de los más de
100.000 sudaneses que han salido de su
país según el alto comisionado de las
Naciones Unidas para los refugiados
una cantidad alarmante en solo tres
semanas de conflicto entre el ejército
regular y el grupo paramilitar fuerzas
de acción rápida las fronteras están
desbordadas como aquí en Egipto también
en chat donde los campamentos para
refugiados ya estaban llenos de su
daneses que huyeron del conflicto
anterior que resultó en la independencia
de Sudán del sur los Sur sudaneses
refugiados en Sudán también han tenido
que retornar a su país bajo el peligro
de represalias una amenaza inestabilidad
en la región nuestra mayor preocupación
en este momento es que si el conflicto
en Sudán no se detiene pronto el efecto
dominó en toda la región será
significativo a pesar de que el primer
cargamento de ayuda humanitaria del
comité Internacional de la Cruz Roja ya
llegó a Sudán Naciones Unidas advierte
que no hay suficiente recursos hacemos
un llamado a todos los donantes para que
miren a futuro y den dinero en efectivo
a todas las organizaciones humanitarias
que ya estaban operando desde antes en
Sudán sin dinero simplemente no podemos
funcionar la ayuda y el personal
humanitario son necesarios tanto fuera
de las fronteras como dentro de Sudán
donde hay 330.000 desplazados internos